everyone works together to help these
actors breathe life into these
characters from improvised moments to
actors getting rejected it's no easy
task landing a marvel role some of your
favorite marvel heroes didn't even
audition for the part they ultimately
got these are the stories of how our
favorite mcu characters were cast
seriously kid where are you from queens
number one you have to have a lot of
confidence to do what tom holland did
during his audition for spider-man he
didn't just enter a room with chris
evans he flipped into the scene
embodying the web slinger's athleticism
and during his screen test with robert
downey jr the two improvised even though
tom's agents warned him not to she knew
she'd freak out and when she freaks out
i free accountants
just
after seven months of auditioning marvel
had seen enough and announced tom
holland as the new spider-man which
holland learned the same time as the
rest of us
number two zendaya knows how to play a
girl perfectly when she auditioned for
the role she had no idea it was for mj
and spider-man as the casting call was
for girl in movie it wasn't until she
signed an nda and read the script that
she learned what the part was actually
for holland recalls that the producers
knew right away that they had found
their mj nobody could pull off the role
of girl in movie like zendaya does
number three she-hulk wasn't exactly
tatiana maslany's first choice she
stated that she auditioned for multiple
marvel roles but got rejected each and
every time i like truly auditioned for
this i love auditioning it seems as if
marvel finally came to their senses as
they cast maslany as the big green
attorney at law the luxury of having the
director there as much as it's
terrifying that's the job we're not sure
what other roles she auditioned for but
she stated she is quite happy with how
everything worked out
number four who better the cast in a
marvel film than a massive marvel fan
amon valani is obsessed with the comics
and specifically miss marvel's character
so getting cast as the hero was a dream
come true valani found out about the
casting call through her aunt who
forwarded her the information and valani
recalls it not looking too legit super
sketchy i don't know what casting calls
look like she sent in her audition tape
at 3 am and found out months later on
her last day of school that she had
landed the role this was actually her
first acting job which is an extremely
impressive way to kick off your career
number five can you imagine anyone else
playing the god of thunder in the mcu
apparently marvel initially could they
turned hemsworth down at first and chris
completely understood i think my
audition sucked i think that was that
was the response i got hemsworth had to
reach shakespearean s dialogue for his
audition
when i discovered an especially rare
breed of butterfly
so we can understand it being a little
difficult chris's younger brother liam
actually almost ended up landing the
role but was turned down for being too
young chris was then called back in and
he nailed it his second time around
number six how do you like them apples
simulu's first audition for shanghi
included reading two scenes from
goodwill hunting and liu couldn't resist
imitating matt damon i got my ten rings
ma it may seem like a weird choice but
casting director sarah finn was
impressed with everything he did he went
through a long and arduous audition
process and he completely nailed every
audition liu actually predicted his
casting way back when chongqi was first
announced he tweeted okay marvel we
gonna talk or what freaky
number seven doctor strange could have
looked very different director scott
derrickson had no doubts about who he
wanted to play the sorcerer supreme
benedict was always our first choice for
the role but even though cumberbatch had
an amazing audition and was offered the
role he initially couldn't take it due
to scheduling conflicts with another
project he was working on at the time
marvel wanted him so badly though that
they pushed back production of the movie
to accommodate cumberbatch that is some
real sorcery from benedict
number 8 we almost got a different black
widow emily blunt was actually cast
which really bummed out johansen i
wanted to work with john favreau and
robert downey jr and then i did not get
the role and i was pretty bummed about
that blonde had scheduling conflicts
which opened up the door for scarlett's
return and it's safe to say everyone was
happy about how things turned out we
knew that scarlet could bring the depth
and the texture to the character that we
wanted number nine tom is the true
trickster god so much so that he tried
auditioning for the role of thor in the
original movie the audition process
lasted three months and you already know
how it turned out for hiddleston what
you always wanted
he didn't land the role of thor but the
casting directors at marvel saw
something more mischievous in his future
the moment he came in and read though it
was loki number 10 it's ned's world and
we're just living in it jacob batalon
had very little acting experience before
his role as ned in spider-man homecoming
it was his first ever audition and he
never believed he would get the role
battalon said that the audition was
nerve-racking for him tom had a really
good time but i was shaking in my shoes
at least zendaya and tom holland both
seem to really enjoy batolon's audition
tapes number 11 chadwick boseman was a
true king through and through bozeman
originally auditioned to play drax in
guardians of the galaxy but he wasn't
quite the right fit for the character
the casting director said that bozeman
played the character like a king
every cell
in my body united in one single purpose
which didn't work for drax but did work
for another character they were
introducing two years later but when it
came time to cast black panther i was
very sure of him for that role
number 12 he is iron man robert downey
jr's audition went exactly how you would
expect it to go he had charisma charm
and had everyone in the room laughing
there it is there's a smile it's okay
yeah so it's natural less less muscles
to smile downey got into the mindset
that there was nobody else that could
possibly get the role but him i don't
want to caught an out about experience
but it was one of those rushes it seems
everyone in the world knows that hiring
downey as iron man was unquestionably
the right move i think hiring robert
downey jr was the best decision we've
ever made how about that
number 13 if it isn't star prince or
maybe it's captain america since that's
the role pratt initially auditioned for
and by the time you do jimmy could be
dead how do you know he isn't already
well i don't i'm not going to sit around
here and wait for someone to tell me he
didn't get that role and almost didn't
get the role of star ward as james gunn
resisted auditioning pratt and i went to
james and he said chris pratt
no way he's totally wrong gunn was
finally convinced to let pratt audition
and 10 seconds in james gunn looked at
casting director sarah finn and said
he's the guy pratt's screen test
alongside dave bautista featured some
hilarious improv and we can see why gunn
was so quick to change his mind it's a
cassette compilation tape
number 14 we stan stan the winter
soldier wanted to be captain america and
he gave a great audition he just wasn't
right for the part casting director
sarah finn said they saw a bit of
darkness in his performance that was
better suited for bucky
number 15 another actor who went for a
completely different role karen gillan
auditioned for agent 13 and captain
america the winter soldier but they saw
something else in her performance karen
was someone who was an incredibly
grounded and solid actor when they
brought her back in to read for nebula
they were originally going to let her
use her natural scottish accent which
you can hear in her audition tape the
disdain that brims only for our way of
life but i am at my brain james gunn
stated that gillen's audition was his
favorite of any of the guardians of the
galaxy actors
number 16 expect disappointment and
you'll never really be disappointed dave
bautista went into his audition for drax
with low expectations but that didn't
stop him from nailing his part he went
through months of auditioning and
chemistry tests which found him doing a
screen test alongside chris pratt he
bounced improv off him including his
famous finger on throat line why would i
put my finger on his throat it was an
instant connection between the two and
it was clear there was no other choice
for star-lord's right-hand man we didn't
know each other had never met each other
and we just clicked
number 17 roland's casting as thanos was
inevitable he wasn't sure how the motion
capture performance would work so he
watched videos of benedict cumberbatch
giving his mocap performance in the
hobbit he took inspiration from the
performance to create his own
performance as thanos he's such an
amazing performer and so uniquely suited
to thanos
number 18 higher further faster brie
larson first tried joining the marvel
empire back in phase 1 when she
auditioned for both thor and iron man 2.
years later marvel gave larson a call to
tell her they wanted her to play captain
marvel which she initially refused
multiple times oh i can't do that like i
have too much anxiety that's too much
for me um i don't think i can handle
that after several months she was
finally convinced to take the part after
reading the script and meeting all the
writers i remember my team being really
proud of me because they knew that it
was a big step for me number 19 from
disembodied voice to a real boy don't
forget paul bettany's vision was first
and foremost the ai voice of tony
stark's jarvis assistant betany had no
inkling of an idea back in 2008 that he
would ever get a chance to play the
vision in the mcu but when avengers age
of ultron came around joss whedon came a
knocking my phone rang and it was just
whedon and he said do you want to be the
vision in the avengers and i went yes i
do number 20. mackie's so good he never
even had to audition he was always
marvel's first choice to play the falcon
and they immediately offered him the
role we just offered him the role in my
memory he did not audition that's only
happened a handful of times at marvel
mackie did however audition for the
mandarin in iron man 3 which caught the
attention of winter soldier directors
the russo brothers he has charisma but
he also has the ability to convey
integrity in a way that very few actors
can we had no idea how different the
face of the mcu could have been if
things just went slightly different but
we're more than happy with what we got
and these actors proved that they
deserved the parts they landed which
audition story did you find most
surprising let us know down in the
comments and thanks for stopping by at
the things